[Music]
machine gun kelly put his black
tongue and love for megan fox on full
display at the 2021 billboard music
awards
it's mind-blowing the bloody valentine
singer attended the event in los angeles
on sunday showing off his chest tattoos
in a black balman
jacket while his girlfriend stunned in a
sexy black cutout moogler dress
and if all that wasn't hot enough they
turned the temperature up
like way up posing for the cameras with
their hands
all over each other that's hard to top
that one man and while that had heads
turning
so did mgk's black tongue the musician
teased the look on his insta story ahead
of the show
posting this clip of his tongue getting
a die job
et spoke to mgk's stylist who dished on
the inspo behind the black tongue
saying it was 100 percent machine gun
kelly's
idea and added that they were excited to
try a look they've never done before
quote he always knows how to turn the
dial up to 110
in the most rad way possible the 31 year
old musician
also documented his manicure on
instagram black and white nails
which he later showed off to the cameras
on sunday
[Music]
mgk received two nominations for this
year's ceremony
top rock album for tickets to my
downfall
and top rock artist both of which he won
but before he walked up to the stage to
accept the trophy for top rock artist
he and megan shared another super steamy
kiss
he also shared this clip to instagram
posing with the billboard music award in
the bathroom
yes t let's
go dude the big wins come just weeks
after a source told et that machine gun
kelly's relationship with megan is
stronger than ever
and that he would marry her in a
heartbeat the pair first met
in march 2020 on the set of their movie
midnight in the switchgrass
and in march of this year a source told
et that the two are
very in love adding quote mgk
always puts megan first treats her like
a queen and is super respectful
thoughtful and funny which are all
qualities that she loves
mgk is head over heels for megan and
didn't think he'd get so lucky to score
someone of her caliber
one thing's for sure this couple
certainly knows how to turn
heads and tongues